[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'attends ta son journal pour lire l ol
j'espère qu'elles seront tous
assure-t-elle brian grant thorton cna et
barzi bave sur qu'outil des petits
commérages le petit écho de la forêt ces
intrus vrai il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
voyant vrai grand coeur raconte notre
journal aujourd'hui oraux aux tiens
tiens tiens boris le loup a du vague à
l'âme en pourquoi ce brave boris at il
du vague à l'âme mois est très triste et
de piquer cigogne est répartie ou à mes
sentir seul lourdement seul toit pas
comprendre animal n'était pas un animal
c'est un accordéon un cours d'eau mais
ouais un mât frimas de musique et d
écoute moi pouvoir faire ludique aussi
avec cordoba vert et boris à la
charmille notre charmante du score
data pas vainqueur mais l'udc
si tu appelles musique sopot abominable
je ne suis pas de tortue autant être
minutieux être musicien c'est un métier
est un métier ça s'apprend puisque les
personnes aimées m'amuser moi aller très
loin en fait comme très bien
hybris tous tristes s'éloigna mieux que
sa prod
mais comme moi prendre à prod
marys moi je connais la musique comme
toi prendre le j'étais en vacances avec
des rossignols
il montre des échos beaucoup notre os
une ue mais tu me connais moi à l'envers
si ce que je te propose et on leur vie
plus boris pendant des jours et des
jours si bien que ça devient inquiétant
waiting on peut aller nous devrions
passer ou la vie des richesses dans les
petites écoles et la forêt et tu n'as
pas honte de rire pendant que nous
faisons tout du mauvais sont pas venus
pour lui il était si mignon avec son
accordéon et les mets pas si mal qu est
simple et tout est une nuit tout triste
tombe mais sur les douze coups de minuit
ellis et luzy agissante
je
pour tirer que l'accord dit on
boris était trop fins de retour au
boulot vous aimez record d re matin
avoir appris à l'école tableau senior
non des rickshaws boris paix des braves
judiciaire
tout fier et heureux boris donne un
concert à nos amis tous rémy
[Musique]
encore
et
m
on dit que la musique adoucit les moeurs
c'est vrai mais il faut savoir en jouer
et pour savoir en jouer il faut
apprendre comme l'a fait boris n'est ce
pas cher telle est fan